there's one thing we can all agree on
the Islamic state group propaganda
machine is absolutely terrifying but
it's effective as we speak their media
center is producing slick multilingual
hollywood-esque videos and distributing
them on social media platforms like
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr they
recorded beheadings and mass slaughters
are too many to ignore just like our
colleagues at other news organizations
we at aj+ faced a dilemma how do we
report news of out Isis especially in
the absence of independent journalists
on the ground how should we handle their
pornographic violence their news
programs and their softer more emotional
messages it's all clearly intended to
manipulate the world's perception of
them should we rebroadcast it on our
platforms should we ignore it and refuse
to engage with it altogether if this is
our generation's information war how do
we win whereas journalists do we
position ourselves on that battlefield
propaganda in wartime is nothing new
it's used to strike fear in the hearts
of enemies and break down their will to
fight it also maintains unity and
goodwill among allies banded together
for a common goal the Nazis were experts
at it so are the Russians the Israelis
the Chinese and the Americans and
weapons of mass destruction the list
goes on but the tactics of modern
propaganda have changed even in just the
last few years it wasn't too long ago
that Osama bin Laden had to find a
middleman to deliver his grainy VHS
tapes from his cave to a media outlet
willing to broadcast his messages even
then journalists ultimately decided what
was or wasn't shared with the world but
that isn't up to us anymore social media
has democratized the spread of
information anyone anywhere can post a
message the
sieved success of Isis is through these
tools and this strategy is problematic
for journalists their propaganda has
crowded out independent journalists who
undermine their narrative and reporting
on this conflict is deadly the recorded
beheadings of james foley and steven
sotloff were meant to horrify western
audiences and grab our attention but
they also sent a clear message to other
reporters don't come here or you pay
with your life it's also a message many
Syrian and Iraqi journalists have been
forced to confront as Isis tries to
silence them with threats kidnapping and
execution even more complicated is their
approach they've crafted a central
message that isn't just spread through
videos of savagery they try to control
their own narrative using a diversity of
voices news programs hosted by hostages
to tell their own version of events -
pictures of their daily life using
selfies or cats to balance media reports
of their brutality many of our
colleagues in the industry have
participated in a media blackout anytime
a brutal video emerges for some that
means not using Isis's footage in
conveying the news others incorporate
still images from the videos because
they feel that it conveys the broader
story with less of the propaganda when
news of James Foley's execution broke
aj+ chose to show bits from the video we
reacted in the moments but we have since
reversed that decision I think we became
aware of the terrible theatricality of
Larissa's was doing with their video and
that with each successive offering we
drew back and I think now we're very
comfortable with with talking about it
but without being part of this this kind
of theatrical presentations know what
Isis does is of significant news value
but we don't want to be their megaphone
it's a tough decision to make and
there's no easy answer so how should we
tell this story
you